rolling and see hello rewind karen
warden with film courage the radio show
outside the studio with filmmaker Alex
Ferrari why don't Larson I do very
excited and I'm our team of researchers
behind the scenes found this quote from
you Alex and I'm gonna read it here as I
stated above the amazing and wonderful
Final Cut Pro for my money I will always
add it on FCP screw added in line of
everything changes today do you still
feel this way um people mean mean yes
absolutely I do I still believe that
final cut is going to be good I know
that a lot of final cut seven still a
wonderful and the one with the current
version other than is the aforementioned
Final Cut X that is all flustered
basically with bona fide access my
feeling it says I've seen it i flopped
at it they've rebuilt it from the ground
up and it's changing the way people edit
and a lot of people are unhappy with
that I think in about a year and a half
or two years I think Final Cut X will be
at a point where we'll be beware final
cut seven is as far as the accessibility
outputting professionalism I think they
just needed to be this difficult up and
it will get to that point I poke like it
doesn't it doesn't support rent it
doesn't support a broadcast monitor that
you can't really afford it there's a
that doesn't support anything lot of the
other formats it's still in its infancy
so just like when Final Cut Pro
originally came out found cup one the
lock you know is a lot of different in
Final Cut two or three or four or five
it was massive changes as it went along
so I think that's what's going to happen
now I think that Apple made a mistake by
not supporting the old final cut or like
we're not supporting it anymore i think
a lot of people are pissed at that a lot
of people are trying to jump on premier
or
avid or something like that for me I'm
always going to be on final cut if it's
available I think eventually maybe Apple
will sell it to somebody else because
it's such a massive base of a user base
that they just can't let a user base
like that died it's stupid that would
probably sell it off to a black magic or
a quantel or somebody that will take it
and move it forward but Apple I think
still believes a lot in it because they
actually rebuilt it from screwing up so
they spent a lot of money to put
together Final Cut X so only time will
tell but until then I have my final cut
seven I'm quite happy okay and your
company is numb robot in Toluca Lake
California mm-hmm tell us about it um
num robot is a company I started back in
I've been in post since 96 my main
company was an English actor and then I
opened up robot in 05 06 after broken
was released because I have a lot of
filmmakers come to me saying hey I saw
what you did i'm broken i wanna i want
to hire you to do that on my film so I
said well let me just open up a new
company and include visual effects and
things like that in it um and we've been
open since 04 05 06 and we just got here
in Los Angeles about three and a half
years ago and we've been doing very very
well where we have a new facility in
toluca lake right by warner brothers and
we do color grading on a da Vinci we do
visual effects editorial all sorts of
color grading post-production
supervision red camera round red camera
workflow and all deliverables hds art HD
cams anything that a filmmaker might
need to get their movie on to the
product place and we also do we have
deals with the for DCPS digital cinema
packages as well as this film out as
well as OEM we do everything and do
everything okay so in all of the
projects that have come to you he worked
on I'm sure over dozens of them what do
you impress by and then what are you not
impressed by what are you seeing as some
of the
and some of the cons of what comes to
you um I think the biggest the biggest
thing that I'm impressed with is they
got it mate you know that they got money
you know it's the biggest the biggest
challenge you know someone wrote me a
check today for a million-dollar I can
go make a movie come it will make maybe
two movies it's always facts but always
impresses me like how did you get the
money it's always been the biggest thing
how do you get the money the thing is
the biggest thing for filmmakers at
least for me because all the other
elements I have kind of culvert I've got
posted on production I've got I can get
it done from point A to point B it's
just getting the money to get the engine
running so the thing that presses me
most is usually that they got the money
and that they got out and did it you
know I did a movie called ups Olivia
that won Sundance won two awards at
Sundance and it was a small little film
made for about 200 grand wonderful
director absolutely just fell in love
with her she's one of her and her
husband just just kind of like pulled up
their bootstraps and made this little
movie with no main act no major actors
in it no mate no no known actors little
little story and they submitted into
Sundance and he got pics accepted is
more than 13 in competition and that
still today still blows me away I'm so
proud to be a part of that project I
just spoke to her the other day we're
getting ready to do a blu-ray release on
it so I'm go back and do some work on it
and you know that kind of sucks kind of
stuff impresses me because she was so
heartfelt about the kind of story she
was trying to tell it's a basically an
environmental film wrapped up in a love
story that you never see you never feel
that it's being preachy so I was really
well written and well-directed and they
won Best Cinematography in the Opera to
Sloan award at Sundance and I was really
really proud like I said to be part of
that um so those kind of things really
impressed me that you know someone who
really has a good place in the heart
it's not coming from place of ego which
in this town I'm sure you met a couple
of egos a lot of filmmakers a lot of
filmmakers I feel things that don't
impress me is filmmakers who come in who
think their entourage you know they they
want to live the life they you know I
have projects or the director was out in
strip clubs while I'm editing you know
and then comes in like well what's wrong
wasn't this cutting
I didn't like dude because you've been
in a strip club if so I'm like dude
really stuff like that so ah you know
those kind of ego places really don't
you know if you got the money and you
did it I just I'm not impressed with
that kind of stuff people who want to
live the lifestyle and not make films
you know there any for the wrong reasons
so those things really kind of
disheartened me a lot of times and a lot
of times it's all about he goes it's all
about ego since you know I did a project
I had 30 producers on it I'm not joking
30 producers on it and everybody had
their saying who's fonts bigger and
where am I on the line and I'm like oh
my god this is crazy so you know if you
don't come from a place of ego and I
guess is the scoop I would like to work
with filmmakers who want a big film
who's about making film about trying to
change the world through their art in
one way shape or form whether that be an
action movie that helps you escape for a
second or a documentary that makes you
think about the meaning of life you know
those are they both have their place but
as long as you're coming from a place of
wanting to you know I think Spielberg
always wants to entertain you once you
take you out of that place while other
directors I feel sometimes just here we
go what would you say are the five red
flags where someone's coming from place
at ego versus the five points with
someone coming from a place of just
wanting to do the work great question um
I guess people who are interested in the
product and that in themselves is
probably one of the flags of being a
place of being a humble filmmaker who
wants to tell a good story someone want
to tell the story someone was not ended
about them someone who doesn't really
care about where their name is how their
name is presented they're going to be
wrong you have to market yourself in
this business it's business still but um
people who put the movie first and not
themselves first is the big plus Hey
look for that in any aspect of
filmmaking from from the sound guide to
the actor who put the movie first
because at the end of the day it's not
about to them it's about the movie it's
about the story you're trying to tell so
I think that's a good sign of a good
director who's putting the story first
before they put themselves
first I don't think the opposite of that
coin is that directors a lot of times or
producers or actors or any of these
people will put themselves first like
how does this going to make me look
what's this going to do for me I want
this I want that I mean if I tell you
stories of things that have happened
it's just the places of ego you just sit
there my wife is a social worker and
she's not in the business at all and she
just sits there in awe of life these
people are ridiculous if I like the ego
is amazingly they think they're curing
cancer when I know I deal with children
who have real problems in shorts as a
Children's Hospital with burn victims
and amputees and things like that like
those are real problems you know they're
like my phone's not big enough I'm like
wow so those are the kind of things that
those are kind of red flags but I've
been blessed that most people that come
to me usually have been very very good
and I do everything in my heart to try
to get their project out to the world at
the best technical quality as possible
whether that be color grading visual
effects making sure we handle the
technical aspects of things so they
don't have to worry about it which i
think is one big downfall with log
filmmakers they don't understand the
technical aspect of things it's not like
the olden days where you shoot film you
cut it and you put it out it good tech
the workflow has changed so dramatically
and it changes daily daily from camera
to camera from editing system to editing
system in color and visual there's a
thousand ways to skin the cat when there
used to be only one so if a filmmakers
not aware of those workflows I think
it's a big entrance to them as a
filmmaker because if you're not a
technical filmmaker nowadays and don't
understand your tools it's like Picasso
an understanding paint or not
understanding a brush it's the same
thing you really have to understand the
tools that you have at your disposal
because you know what the first time I
ever worked with a techno crane number
if you've ever had the opportunity to
shoot with a techno crane I did a music
video with one and it changed my life I
never want to shoot without the
technocrane again it's a computerized
crane that goes in and out and moves and
does all this kind of stuff and I was
just like oh my god this is it's like
this is this is like the first time you
ever work with the Steadicam like oh my
god like so if you don't understand
these tools and what where they're
supposed to be used
early then you're just not using all the
brushes in your box
Oh